- Même s'ils prennent de plus en
plus de place sur nos routes
et qu'ils alourdissent la
congestion, toutes les raisons
sont bonnes pour les acheter.
- Parce que j'ai trois enfants,
on fait du sport et on a besoin
d'une plus grosse voiture.
- Parce qu'on ne voyage pas
léger.
- Principalement, c'est pour
la traction intégrale.
- C'est pour la sécurité, puis
ce n'est pas pour l'économie
d'essence certain, ah, ah.
- Depuis 1990, le nombre
de camions légers, comme les
véhicules utilitaires sport et
les camionnettes de type pick-
up, a pratiquement quadruplé
sur les routes canadiennes,
alors que le nombre de voitures
standard, lui, a grimpé
d'à peine 10%. Leur popularité
est grandissante.
ANDRÉANNE BRAZEAU, analyste en
mobilité, Équiterre
- En 2021, c'est quatre
véhicules neufs vendus sur cinq
qui sont des camions légers au
Canada. Puis, au Québec, en fait
depuis 2015, y'a plus de camions
légers qui se vendent que de
voitures également. L'impact
sur les émissions de GES est
vraiment important. En fait,
c'est ça qui, en ce moment,
nous freine dans l'atteinte
de nos cibles climatiques.
- Depuis 1990, les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre des camions
légers ont grimpé de 156 %,
trois fois plus que celles de
l'ensemble du parc automobile
canadien, qui ont augmenté
de 49 %. Le bilan aurait été
bien meilleur si
les consommateurs avaient
continué à acheter de plus
petites voitures.
CATHERINE MORENCY,
Polytechnique Montréal
- On a vraiment raté l'occasion
là... En rendant ces véhicules
plus efficaces énergétiquement
parlant, bien, on a finalement
encouragé les gens à acheter
des véhicules plus gros en
maintenant leur niveau de
consommation énergétique.
- Et ils sont de plus en plus
gros. Selon un rapport
d'Équiterre, en 25 ans,
la hauteur des camions légers
a augmenté de 7 %, la surface
qu'ils occupent au sol de 11 %
et leur masse de 25 %.
C'est donc beaucoup d'espace
perdu, notamment dans le Grand
Montréal.
- Pendant les 20 dernières
années, c'est l'équivalent
de 17 parcs Lafontaine d'espace
qui ont été perdus en
stationnement, en espace urbain.
- Pour freiner les ventes de
camions légers, Équiterre pense
que la publicité doit être
encadrée pour qu'on y affiche,
par exemple, la consommation
d'essence ou les GES produits
par ces véhicules.
- Les constructeurs savent que
l'électrification est à nous
porte. Mais ils vont quand même
justement faire la promotion
des plus gros véhicules, plus
énergivores, parce que la marge
de profit est plus élevée
en ce moment.
- Parmi les autres propositions,
une taxe à l'achat,